[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without me
[Music]
all right Ryan before we dive into this
special LIVE episode man this is one of
my favorite events this one was in
Indianapolis but we had who might the
person who might be my favorite musician
right now yeah he didn't just open up
the show but then we dragged him on to
the on to the podcast and talked about
his podcast and talked about his album
that's coming out today actually so this
this episode is coming out August 25th
and Andrew Bell is on this episode with
us and it was such a great time I'm I
haven't listened to thee because we're
recording this before the album comes
out I haven't listened to the album yet
well it's funny cuz you just said it's
coming out today and I got so excited
I'm like I'm like wait a minute we're
recording this for August 25th right I
mean we've heard a few of the singles
that have come out so far and they're so
so good I've - he just he's the most
intentional musician he really is he
takes five years to put together an
album unbelievable he spins that whole
five years working on the album yeah
it's it really is unbelievable
so Andrew Bell's new album is out today
it's called dive deep you can get it
wherever you get albums these days
a local CD connections Ryan and I used
to go to these overnight things remember
in 1997 wu-tang's Forever album camp
dude I snuck out of my house your mom
all rolled up with the lights off my
driveway
[Laughter]
no she wasn't she knew that it was no
big deal and that my dad was
overreacting a little little too strict
yeah we went out to the midnight sale it
was a school night - yeah and we got Wu
Tang forevers album at midnight when the
CD connection in Middletown Ohio opened
and I mean I guess I don't know if
there's a midnight sail for the dive
deep album by Andrew Bell but but it's
already after midnight so you can go to
iTunes or title or Spotify or wherever
you listen to to your music these days
you can buy the album you can stream it
check it out and in the podcast we also
mentioned that his last album which came
out it was almost five years ago I think
was like four or four and a half years
ago it's called black bear it's my
favorite album in the last five years
it's brought it's it's the album of the
decade so forth if it's not yeah if it's
not if it's not my number one it's my
number two yeah and so we brought him on
the podcast we also talked about his
podcast that he puts out there and it's
a podcast is different from any other
podcast that that I've listened to
because it's a podcast about food which
you're like how could you have a podcast
about whoo and you're a musician but
it's a podcast about childhood via food
memories is is the best way that I could
describe it it's called Systema we'll
put a link to his album we'll put a link
to his podcast in the show notes before
we dive into that episode though Ryan
let's talk real quick we're hitting the
road again next week man we're headed to
Canada and if you just listen to our
last episode which came out a few days
ago we went through all the dates I'll
just go through them really quickly we
have a bunch of special guests on many
of these dates but only a few tickets
are left in Canada we'll be in Toronto
Ottawa Montreal Vancouver Calgary and
Edmonton Edmonton might be sold out
actually most of these might be sold out
by the time this comes out but you can
Hedda les is now calm it's called the
lessons now tour Ryan and I give an
in-depth talk about minimalism and we
also record a live version of the
podcast we dish out a bunch of hugs
afterward almost all of Canada is sold
out at this point but find a few
straggler tickets in there if you can
les is now calm from there we're headed
over to New York we have three stops in
New York City two of those were sold out
Manhattan is sold out Brooklyn is sold
out but we have a new stop set up in
Brooklyn on September 20th dude I just
gotta mention yeah that Scott from
charity:water
is gonna be at that first Brooklyn stop
yes so it's not sold out yet and if you
like cherry drew water
and if you've seen any of Scott's videos
I mean he's just he's an unbelievable
character so anyway it it's it's well
worth it's well worth the ticket yeah
definitely and by the way if you're in
Montreal or our friend Julian Smith will
be joining us in in Montreal
I know budget we had a bunch of folks
from Montreal come to our Vermont's
table we when we were in Vermont yeah
that's early this year and so I talked
to a bunch of people there who were like
yeah and then I'll see you again in
September so a few tickets left in
Montreal Julian Smith he's the founder
of breather he's one of my favorite most
prolific authors but then he stopped
writing and I want to talk to him about
why he stopped writing and decided to
start a business instead so we'll record
that on the podcast as well Philadelphia
on September 21st and then we're headed
over to Salt Lake City our friend
Courtney Carver will be there with us
October 5th and the next night Denver
that one might be sold out already go
ahead and check if you're in Denver and
you haven't haven't gotten tickets yet
Denver might already be sold out and in
Phoenix we have a friend Joshua Becker
from becoming minimalist he's going to
be at the live show there and on the
podcast and in Texas we have three stops
in Texas Austin Dallas and Houston
Austin has already sold out our friend
Cruz Spence will be there with us given
out relationship advice and then we're
gonna be in the south ryan nashville
washington DC atlanta and tampa we have
special guests at all of those nashville
griffin house will be there playing
music but also talking about an
amateur's perspective on minimalism and
then washington DC Cal Newport famed
professor also author computer
scientists and all-around outstanding
guys gonna make us look like a bunch of
children because he's so smart we'll do
our best to keep up with him in
Washington DC that's a huge theater and
that one's almost sold out
Atlanta JP Sears will be making fun of
us on stage for 90 minutes we're
basically just getting roasted that
night roast of the minimalists yes come
to our Atlanta stop there are still some
tickets available there Tampa
might be sold out at this point we're
trying to find a few more tickets for
that or maybe even a bigger theater I
don't know if that's going to work head
on over les is now calm to check that
out we're trying to get our frame
brother Cephas to open up as well my
favorite music so far this year I think
has been brother C vs EP called not that
important no listen I you've got to
check it out man it's so good and then
we're ending the North American tour in
December no better place than Detroit
and Milwaukee bring your puffer jacket
Ryan you know dude it's gonna be cold I
won't be able to wear my you know
barefoot shoes neon zero shoes you could
you could be like wim HOF you know he
like scaled part of Mount Everest and
like shorts and barefoot I guess you
could do that in Detroit you might step
on some glass though I'm just happy
we're going to Detroit man yeah man
we've never had a tour stop in Detroit
and we've always happy I mean we've been
close yeah we were in Ann Arbor right
but but we'll actually be in Detroit now
- Saginaw
we've never been to Saginaw yeah we did
tour stop in Saginaw screw Detroit we're
going to Saginaw y'all and they're not
we'll be in Detroit then we're headed to
Flint and Pontiac
John again remember we wanted this intro
to be shorter hey why don't you why are
you hating on Pontiac Michigan I got
nothing against Pontiac Michigan all
right well if you're in Saginaw you're
in Pontiac you're in Flint come on down
to the Detroit stop and then oh let's
see Milwaukee is we're ending the year
Milwaukee Wisconsin
that isn't Wisconsin saving the best for
last yeah well that's not even the
actual last though because then in March
well the last for 2017
yes but March 2018 were headed on over
to Australia New Zealand I know I'm so
pumped
yeah man those side we go back we have
Methodist it's 2014
no it's been it'll be almost four years
yeah you know so in our audience is
growing significantly man yeah in
Australia so we didn't have a pop cast
back then no and we still were selling
out I mean you remember like Sydney was
our biggest tourist ah like after that
point yeah it was a 1400 people there
yeah it was nuts and so and then so
we'll be in Sydney most likely will be
in Melbourne we'll be in Brisbane we'll
be an Auckland maybe some others as well
if you're on our email list over at the
let's calm you'll be the first to know
actually we'll be the second to know the
people who are the very first to know
will be our patreon supporters you get
an email before tickets are available -
even to the public so patreon supporters
get first access to all of our events
before they go on sale to the public and
by the way we're doing a bunch of bonus
episodes over at patreon as well so you
can find those right now you can find
old bonus episodes we're doing live
streams we're trying to do a a bunch
more short and experimental things and
that's all free if you are a patreon
supporter head on over to patreon comm
slash the minimalists or you can just go
to the minimalists com click on the
donate button at the top anyone who
supports us with two bucks or more you
could access to all of those private
podcasts that don't go out to the world
but Ryan and I it we're so much more
freeing to like I feel like it's I feel
like I didn't say anything cuz it's such
an intimate like group of people yeah we
just get Nate like a million downloads
yeah turn the mics on and what happens
we're like minimalism
but it's so much fun to do those and and
we can do short experimental ones and by
the way if you support us on patreon
none of that money goes to me or goes to
Ryan it it goes to building a podcast in
film studio which is what we're working
on we want to do a lot more video
content if you loved our documentary
we're doing some mini documentaries
we're filming interviews we're gonna do
a bunch of other cool stuff we've got
some other good announcements coming in
in the coming week so make sure you
subscribe to our regular podcast on
iTunes or or wherever actually something
called iTunes anymore man they call it
Apple podcast you know it's gonna stick
I don't care yeah so wherever you
subscribe to podcast subscribe to this
support us on patreon if you can afford
it we really appreciate that it keeps
our podcast 100% advertisement free Ryan
should we dive into this episode it's
called deep and it was in Indianapolis
Indiana at the Egyptian room which was
such I mean honestly it was my top 3 of
all of our tour stops oh it's so funny
how like you and I have different tastes
it was an outstanding tour stop I loved
him but it was probably like one of my
least favorite because there were so
many outstanding tour stops no you know
tell you what made that tour stop if it
was to be one of my favorites well
actually I'll say this it was my
favorite tour stop so far when it comes
to the special guests that we've had
yeah and and we've had some outstanding
guests but like Andrew Bell dude I'm
just gonna say it man the album black
bear makes my heart sing man yeah we
played that out but it doesn't get
played out it's the Elm I've ever played
out that like you stopped listening to a
couple weeks you can go right back to it
like it's if you if it was on cassette
like it would be that one cassette that
just won't break even though you keep
playing it over and over and so man I'm
guessing I'm gonna be doing the same
thing with with his new album dive deep
yeah all right check the show notes
y'all will see you on tour really soon
we've got some other exciting news
coming up I think it's next week we're
gonna know it's in two weeks we're gonna
be talking about we're moving somewhere
and we're gonna talk about it we've been
in Montana for the last five years we're
goin somewhere else so he continued
alright y'all we'll see you soon
see you next time my name is Joshua
fields Milburn and I am Ryan Nicodemus
and together we are the minimalists and
we are live at the Egyptian room and
Indianapolis Indiana hello y'all
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're gonna have some fun tonight
we're gonna answer some of your
questions we have a microphone set up
somewhere over here so whoever wants to
break the seal here's what happens
there's always a trepidatious person and
they and they don't start but there are
like five hundred plus people here
tonight we can't answer all the
questions in the hug line afterward and
so now is the best time to ask questions
we'll try to get to 6 plus questions
tonight and but first let's talk about
touring real quick Ryan your hand right
now looks like it took viagra yeah if
that lasts for longer than four hours
consult your doctor I got stung by a
wasp a couple days ago and yeah it's
just look a little mutated right now man
we and stuff happens on tour we yeah
we've been on the road and crazy things
happen someone hit me in a hit and run
yesterday and Dayton Ohio
everything was fine I don't even know if
he knows that he hit me it was like this
big-ass truck and his wheel his back
wheel just sort of took off half of the
bumper on the rental car and yeah he
just kept going and I was sort of left
there puzzled
scratching my head and we had someone
break into her car in San Francisco it
was last week though it was it was such
an honor of all the cars on that street
they could have broken into they broke
into ours
the idiots didn't realize we were
minimalists man it's so fun I was like
walking out to get something out of the
van my sunglasses or something and
Podcast Shawn had parked the car and you
know hey where's the car all it's over
on this street take a left so I'm
walking down and I see this van with
like a window busted out I was like
those poor suckers I was like wait a
minute that's our van
luckily there wasn't too much in there I
think they got some of Matt de bellas he
had some like tripods for his cameras
and they opened up all the boxes of
books I don't think any were missing
though so don't worry there are still
some of the lobby afterward no cereal so
they if you can't afford a book tonight
you want to grab one of our books we'd
be happy to buy you a copy tonight
afterwards so we always hang out and
you're welcome to grab one if you can't
afford it thanks just just minimize it
afterward please
you can donate it to local library or
friend family member and enemy someone
we've owned what else happened I uh
there was blood everywhere you already
heard about that though right it was a
podcast episode called blood chocolate
I'll let you go back and listen to that
I bled all over a loves bathroom for an
hour I won't give you any other details
but you can you can figure that one out
how do you what's your name were you
from what's your question hi my name is
rose I am from Ottawa Illinois welcome
thank you I really appreciate Josh that
you do a lot of talking about being an
introvert irony in that I know and I am
an introvert as well so I have a
wonderful gig I am an elementary art
teacher mmm which is wonderful I get to
be with a lot of kids fostering
creativity and watching their minds work
which is amazing it's the best job but
as an introvert I see a thousand kids
every week and it drains me yes so by
the end of each week I'm really
exhausted from all of that so here you
are Josh on the road with seeing
thousands of people all the time yeah
how do you balance doing these kinds of
things and your introverted side to your
personality and you know don't become so
depleted yeah it's an important question
because so I was I'm from Dayton Ohio is
driving around Dayton Ohio
yesterday before the big pickup truck
hit me and I was just remembering that
so my one of the jobs I did at one point
I was a regional manager for a bunch of
retail stores in the greater Dayton area
so which like Springfield Ohio to
Lebanon Ohio is the general area
and I remember I was driving around it
it's very sprawling most Midwestern
cities are pretty sprawling and so it
would sometimes it would take you
half-hour hour hour and a half to get
where I was going but I remembered my
drives around Dayton being more pleasant
than they should be and it was I realize
now like in retrospect I'm looking in
the rearview metaphorically at my you
know 26 year old life or whatever decade
ago and I realized that that was the
only time in my days where I was alone
from the time that I woke up until the
time that I went to bed the only time
that I was ever alone was when I was in
the car and I didn't I didn't realize
that I was an introvert even because I
tried so hard not to be an extrovert but
to have you know constant contact with
people right and I think part of that
was good in fact part of it was
uncomfortable I don't think I could do
this right now if when I did if I didn't
turn 18 and go get a sales job right
away
well I wouldn't got a sales job and I
was so freakin awkward for like the
first year because I wasn't good at
interacting with people but it's just
like any other pattern we want you once
you build that groove you start to be
able to you know I'll never be a master
extrovert but I've learned how to be
more socially competent through
processes like that the problem is when
we overcome and say and then of course I
was spending 90% 95% of my waking hours
around other people and that doesn't
work and so what I do now is I set
expectations with the people closest to
me and they know even with the people
they absolutely close to me Ryan or my
partner Rebecca or Ella or four-year-old
it's hard to do this but it's important
to do it I spend eighty percent of my
time
and I carved that time out accordingly
it's harder to do that on the road but
it's still it's still totally possible
and I find that that's important not
just for me but for the other people
because that other 20 percent I'm so
much better my partner
backs she said the other day when you
know I was playing with Elle on the back
yard she was she was making dinner and
she I'm not a marathon or I'm a sprinter
when I'm with other people and she had
this this observation I realized I'm
really good in short bursts with other
people but if I'm forced to be around
you for hours and hours and hours it's
not you it's me yeah I can definitely
attest to that
Oh blast Josh out to dinner or something
before a show and he's like no like I
got to go walk around man can I walk
with you
no I remember um when his mom had passed
away the girl that he was dating at the
time she like he went down to Florida
and he told me like hey man I'm gonna be
gone for a week you know please don't
call me don't email me and I'm like yeah
no problem like I've known him for so
long I know exactly where he's coming
from and what he needs for himself
and the girl that he was dating calls me
up and she's like Ryan what's what's
wrong with Josh I'm like his mother just
passed away like wow what do you think
is wrong with him and she's like no no
he told me he told me that he didn't he
didn't like wanna you know talk for a
week and that he needed some alone time
and I'm like yeah that's that that's
Josh and she was like Ryan I know you're
his best friend but I am his girlfriend
and IIIi don't know what's going on and
I'm like oh you know I
that's who Josh is and just as I'm
hanging up the phone I'm like well
that's not gonna last very long
but not I think I think Josh brings up a
good point
um you know we all we all have needs and
you know when it comes to Josh and i's
relationship i know what his his needs
are and i give him that alone time and
there are times where i need you know
josh has helped working something out
and if he has the energy will give me
that need but yeah I think the the give
and take is what is what is super
important with any relationship thank
you thank you hi what's your name Erin
and I live in Westfield which is about
20 minutes north of Indianapolis welcome
thanks thank you for coming it's so
surreal to be here with you guys so
close just puts a body with a
disembodied voice I've been told that
I'm the voice in some people's heads
I believe it so my question today is
about goals because like so many of my
peers for the first like eighteen years
of my life
the goal was to go to college but then
when you graduate college in your early
20s it's like well that's it good luck
and you're just kind of sent on your way
so I spent most of my 20s just kind of
being aimless and wandering around and I
decided to fix it with the goal going to
grad school but which gave me another
goal graduating but I'm about 11 months
out from that graduation and I am
terrified about what happens after and I
know I've read that essay that you wrote
about goals life without goals 400 days
like 17 times but it still is scary
about what comes next so if you could
maybe talk about what that looks like or
how that feels or maybe a little
encouragement sure let's talk about it
first so wire goal is important to you I
feel like it helps give me focus or
something to resist against okay that's
good that's good so so maybe let's just
change our language a little bit we've
been enculturated
to to believe that goals are a good
thing and I don't think they're
inherently good or inherently bad I
think they're a thing and sometimes
they're a tool that help us
and so I I did that experiment where I
got rid of goals it ended up being for a
hundred days I didn't say how long at
first because I didn't want that to be a
goal seems like it defeat the purpose
and so I said you know I'm gonna live
without goals a friend of mine leopa
Volta had done and he had written about
it I'm like this sounds interesting and
and so but before that I of course what
used to be the gold guy I mean I had
goals for everything spreadsheets and
formulas and and and I had sub goals and
consumer purchasing goals and vacation
goals fitness goals I had so many goals
they stressed me out and I was actually
I felt like I was constantly behind and
it added to this layer of anxiety onto
me
and I think most of those goals weren't
actually helpful they were
anxiety-producing they didn't help me
focus they kept me scattered and and so
there are were they're worse a few goals
that actually did help me when I when I
focused on a few goals so the way I like
to look at it now is if I'm in a crater
so if I have debt or you know I used to
weigh 80 pounds more than I weigh now
the weight wasn't a goal but being
healthy and then defining what healthy
was to me what was a better goal so so
getting out of a crater is really
important once I'm out of the crater
though I prefer to have a direction
rather than a goal so so here's the way
that you might want to look at it
instead of saying goals maybe what I
would say is try to let go of your
expectations so that's the way I would
reframe it it's it's it's letting go of
the expectations for the thing because
expectations breathe discontent and
instead raise your standards and I'll
give you an example
so a few years ago my favorite thing
that I've ever created is a book called
everything that remains and and Ryan
thank you that person read it
Ryan and I moved to this cabin in the
middle of nowhere Montana to write that
book and I didn't have a goal of I'm
going to finish this book my standard
instead was I'm going to write for three
hours a day every day it ended up being
a lot more than three hours there there
were times where was 14 hours a day but
my standard was a pretty high one anyone
who writes for three hours a day it
knows that you will get a lot more done
than anyone else who is an aspiring
writer and doesn't write at all and and
so I found that my standard was for the
quality of work and it wasn't about
completing the book in fact but Ryan and
I have published three books together
I've also published a novel before and
it was never about finishing the book it
was about the standard of writing and
doing it well and not being not not
being married to perfection because
perfection will mean that it will never
be complete but being being open to the
idea of I'm going to have a high
standard and as long as I can look
myself in the mirror and say I did the
best job I could do given the resources
I had then then I'm gonna give myself
permission to you know publish the thing
or not publish the thing whatever but
I'm more content with the work itself
than I am with that expectation or that
goal and I can tell you this though
every time I have an expectation or a
goal it starts to it starts to stress me
out and I it happens to me all the time
we all have expectations about something
I find expectations creeping into my
life and I want every single event to be
perfect I want I want you know the we
were in LA recently and it was a truly
outstanding event we did a podcast with
Rob Bell and whose yeah he's great I I
really look up to him and and his work
has affected me in profound ways and so
I wanted this thing to go outstanding
and I had this expectation how the night
was going to go
and it was like 99% of the way there and
the whole next day I'm beating myself up
because I didn't meet the goal right I
was 99% to go but it was an outstanding
evening that's because my standards are
high so if I would have let go of the
expectation before then I would have had
a better night and I would actually I
would have been more in the moment I
would have enjoyed it more well I would
say your first goal if you're in debt
from grad school would be to get out of
debt and and and I think that's what you
should start with at the end of the day
- just to think about what your goals
are gonna be when you graduate is
overwhelming the more you stack on top
of it the more overwhelming it's going
to be I mean for me when I was done with
that packing party and trying to pay off
my debt and trying to save money
I took it just a piece at a time it was
like okay my car I'm just gonna focus on
getting rid of this car payment okay my
home I'm going to you know figure out a
way to either sell this home or rent it
out and get rid of this mortgage I took
the same approach when I was you know
putting stuff on Craigslist and selling
it so I think when it comes to goals in
general like the biggest the biggest tip
I can give anyone and I tell my
mentoring students this all the time is
just choose one goal I have people all
the time who come to be like well I want
to start eating healthy and I want to
start exercising regularly and I want to
start you know writing that book and you
know how can I find time to do all three
of those things and the honest answer is
you probably can there's probably
someone out there who could do it don't
get me wrong but that's a pretty pretty
tall pretty tall expectation and I do
have friends who do approach things that
way like I when we moved to Phillipsburg
in that cabin the first person I really
connected with there she was an artist
she painted she sculpted she was a
singer-songwriter she was a writer or I
think I said that didn't I know I didn't
yeah she was a writer so she had like
these four things that she was really
passionate about
and she was like just I just wanted I
just want to figure out how can I earn
you know an income from from doing this
stuff and I told her I'm like you have
to pick one thing and when I said that
she's like oh I knew you were gonna say
that
like I don't want to pick anything I'm
like well you know that that's up to her
right like it's just my two cents anyway
I mean I am wrong sometimes believe it
or not but you know it turns out um she
took the same approach she's at a point
now where she is basically hosting these
like poetry slam open mic night type
things and then she'll bring in special
guests so she's basically you know a
booking agent for poets in Portland
Oregon and she got there by having that
approach it was six years later before
she finally felt comfortable like oh wow
like I'm actually you know doing
something that I like
you know I'm earning a little bit of
income from it but I always give her a
hard time because I'm like hey if you
would have if you would have approached
a little bit differently you could been
doing this three years ago another
lesson to learn from that is the thing
she is doing right now to earn a living
and something sounds like she's
passionate about it wasn't one it
doesn't sound like it was one of the
four things she initially planned to do
while she was back there in Phillipsburg
either and so also be open to pivoting
in a way I mean this this whole
minimalist thing was a beautiful
accident and and I never expected any of
this I never ever expected to be
recognized on the street in unless you
know I was running from the cops or
something yeah there was there was there
was no way and so I what I can tell you
is just be be open to pivoting I wanted
to write fiction and so Ryan can with
the idea of why don't we write some
nonfiction and we didn't even know it
was called a blog at the time and so we
started writing essays on the web and
yeah so so be open to Opie open to that
pivot have you read everything that
remains yeah okay wow I was going to
give you a copy but thank you thank you
for your support I appreciate it you're
the best thank you howdy what's your
name Erica you mind moving that my cup
is the tab that way we can hear you
I found her blog because I moved six
years ago with only the items in my car
to Atlanta and I didn't know anybody
else that like survived and so I was
like googling like and then I was okay
like after I moved and I only had that
stuff I was like I'm okay still so I
started googling purging like what is
this thing I happen up on your blog so
thank you for that I just felt like I
wasn't crazy okay real quick you know
it's amazing we'll get people come to
our events sometimes and they'll say
yeah when I was going off to college 30
years ago I remember I could fit
everything in my car when I first moved
out for the first time put everything in
my car and it was the happiest time in
my life I just wish I could get back to
that I just look at I'm like why can't
you the truth is we don't need to own
nearly as many things as we thought or
we needed to own or we think we need to
own we all need some stuff Ryan and I
aren't here to tell you to get rid of
all of your things and one person's life
who's a minimalist is going to look
different from another person's life and
you don't have to even be at minimum us
you don't have to use that word but if
you're looking to simplify you might you
might start to question you know some of
the things that that will this fit in my
car if I if I need to go or the other
question was like like you know if you
if your house was on fire what would you
grab in 30 seconds or if you had to move
in 30 minutes one of the things you
would grab that might help you identify
what are the some of the things that are
most important Eric
cut you off sorry oh no problem so my
question is about like guilt so I've
always loved fashion vintage and like
thrifting and hunting for birthday
vintage stuff and in so doing that I
resell items online but periodically
I'll feel guilty because I'm still
bringing stuff in even though I'm
selling stuff it's kind of like
business-related so I don't want it like
some tips are insight when you aren't
feeling like minimalist enough even
though I like fashion yeah and there's
nothing there's nothing wrong with
fashion well I say that line at the
beginning my talk about having the
causes [ __ ] closets full of designer
clothes we were in LA recently and I got
a lion got a woo heard some whoo and I'm
not judging that you know I if anything
I just identify with it right because I
had I had excess closed it doesn't sound
to me like the things you're talking
about our access well why do you feel
guilty you think I know a lot about
guilt I grew up Catholic and and so I I
can tell you this
sometimes guilt is just a warning sign
and other times it's it's an unnecessary
emotion and we need to figure out is
this the good kind of guilt like you
know if I went and robbed the bank today
I'm gonna feel pretty guilty about that
right and it's a warning sign and say
hey you just did something wrong but
other times what the guilt might be
saying to you is someone else thinks I'm
doing something wrong and what I've
learned is I care a lot less about what
other people think
and I care a lot more about what I think
and I think it's important to to break
it down that way our producer podcast
Sean who's in
back by the way ladies and gentlemen
podcast Shawn he's hidden in the shadows
as usual he's really the man behind all
the minimalism he helps us out with
everything operations tour podcast and
and his wife does that part-time if she
spends probably 20 hours a week going
out buying things at thrift shops and
she ends up being the the middle man
middle woman is that the appropriate
vernacular
she's the middle person between the the
thrift shop in Missoula Montana
and the person in Indianapolis who wants
to buy the vintage jeans or whatever and
she sells his stuff on Poshmark and and
because that adds value to other
people's lives she earns money from it I
think I think it's a noble thing what
you're doing is actually helping other
people connect with other vintage items
which by the way is a really responsible
way to buy clothes
yeah I've this shirt I bought a bottle I
bought online used and it was like eight
bucks and in doing that it's it was like
gently used if someone probably wore it
three or four times and they got rid of
it didn't like it for whatever reason
and so someone else didn't have to
recreate that thing and ends up in a
landfill I was able to use it and I'll
continue to use it until it has enough
holes that I decide to get rid of it but
but it's up to you to determine am I
feeling guilty because I'm doing
something wrong or am I feeling guilty
because I'm afraid of other people's
judgement can I tell you where I heard
the guilt in your question it was when
you said and sometimes like sometimes I
get rid of stuff which makes me think
that you know maybe you do come across
like that's a I wish I could pull denim
off I loved it but but you know maybe
you come across an awesome denim jacket
you're like man this is really cool like
I really don't wanna sell this I will
wear this and you keep it and I know
that if I had that attitude towards
clothes or anything I would very quickly
start having junk drawer number six and
seven
um I think when it comes to that guilt
like Josh said I mean be honest with
yourself is it is it someone else
judging you or is it actually something
that you need to look at and if it is
something that you need to look at then
incorporate some rules into your life
that are going to help you at least get
stuff out of the house you know I used
to be like a big fan of the one in one
out rule but I think that can be really
dangerous too so I'm kind of suggesting
that but I'm kind of not suggesting that
but I'll do one in 10 out yeah that's a
good one but yeah I would say that the
guilt is definitely there for reason
it's figuring out where that guilt is
coming from and then acting on if you do
need to act on something by
incorporating rules you know Josh and I
we've got the for those who don't know
about the 9090 rule Josh and I came up
with this thing where it's like all
right I've got this thing I open up you
know my my junk drawer and it starts to
overflow a little bit and instead of
creating junk door number two you know
Mariah and I we make sure that we have
only one junk drawer in the house so
when it starts to overflow I'll have
this thing in there maybe it's like a
you know USB cable don't even know what
it you know attaches to and and it's
just that I'm like wait a minute I don't
even know what this goes to I know I
haven't used it in the last 90 days I'm
probably not gonna use it in the next 90
days so I'm gonna go ahead and I'm gonna
I'm gonna get rid of that and it's
incorporating things like that that I
think will help you feel less guilty
moving forward thank you
Eric have you read our book essential
okay I'd love to give you copy Jessica
you ran here somewhere there's 12
different chapters on intentional living
it's like 12 different areas of
intentional living and one of those
areas is stuff and I think you'll find
value in it
ladies and gentlemen Jessica Williams
yeah
jessica is the woman behind the
minimalism
she runs a great podcast called the mind
palace by the way but and also she does
all of our social media stuff while
we're on the road which is really
helpful and she's should be in the back
with us after we're with the merch as
well before we move on to some more
questions for the folks listening to
this at home if you have a comment or
tip for anyone who's asking a question
today you can give us a call
leave us a voicemail at four zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine or
you can also send a voice memo right
from your phone email it over to podcast
at the minimalists comm and we will air
our favorite comments and tips on a
future episode Ryan do you know what
time it is
oh yeah ma'am tell me it is time for our
hashtag ask the minimalist lightning
round this is uh this is where we answer
questions usually from social media
we're at the minimalists on Twitter and
Facebook and Instagram but since you're
here tonight you're gonna ask a regular
question and and usually we have a while
to give you a really pithy answer but
we'll monitor on until we get something
that's pithy that is tweetable for for
the evening by the way Jess usually does
some live tweeting tonight so you can
find a lot of the things that that we
talked about tonight the the pithy
version that's always in the show notes
as well
so you give us your question normal
question you'll get a normal ish answer
with a bow on top three blocks away and
I love that band it's rather unfortunate
timing with the lightning round I had a
comment I'm the community leader of the
Indianapolis meetup group I just wanted
to say hi to everybody and let everybody
know to go to minimalist org and click
on Indianapolis that will take you to
our Facebook page and you can join our
group we have meetings every month then
we do some fun things too like game
night or happy hour so it's a fun group
and we get to talk about things like
this so while you're still feeling
inspired by these two gentlemen because
I know you will be pleased look us up
and join our group yeah for sure so Amy
runs the the local group here we in 2014
Ryan and I went out to a hundred cities
did a hundred city tour 119 event so we
basically donated a year of our lives to
get out and and spread this message and
the crowd started to grow and people
would come up and say how do I connect
with open-minded people locally and I'd
always say I don't know and and so we
left we left behind 100 local meetup
groups in 100 different cities and this
is one of them Amy thank you so much for
what you do thank you very much what
find deals with relationships and we're
talking about being intentional about
physical items that we bring into our
lives but how can you be more
intentional about the relationships that
you invite into your life because I'm
kind of a friendly person and I make
friends with people very easily and the
next thing I know I have friends not
friendly and that's more demanding on my
time what do you mean let me just expand
on what do you mean you have friends not
rather than rather than just an
acquaintance that I say hello to and
that's good enough it turns into hey
let's go get coffee hey let's go to this
movie hey let's get together and spend
some time together yeah as opposed to
just it's good enough to say hello and
how are you and let's chat about this
thing that interests us both and then
move on our way yeah
so I pithy answer I'll start with that
and then maybe I'll unpack it a little
bit
my pithy answer for you we call these
minimal Maxim's
by the way and I think the answer is
that I'm trying to tweet it in my head
here don't mistake quantity for quality
the people were closest to me in my life
this is my unpacking at this point the
the people who are close to me in my
life
they don't necessarily I don't see them
every day I have some close friends that
I see once a year I have some close
friends who I see once a month
and that's okay Ryan and I don't even
hang out that much I go on tour just so
I think he he goes on tour so he can
hang out with me and and I think it's
okay and it's really about setting those
expectations let the other people know
what your what else you're saying yes to
instead of just saying now the the worst
thing you could tell someone is can't
I'm busy that just means you're out of
your life's out of control but if it's
instead because busy just really means
that you I have no control over my daily
activities instead let them know where I
give Ryan like today Ryan did ask me to
go to dinner with him and I said I'm
really going to enjoy walking around
right then and at that time and he's all
right cool and the people who care most
about you will understand yeah I totally
agree um I'm gonna ramble until
hopefully I get a good fit the answer
but it sounds to me like you are the one
saying yes to all this stuff they're
asking you hey yeah do you want to go
grab a movie and maybe they are a really
cool person if you're telling someone
yes though when it is a detriment to
yourself like if Josh would have said
yes sir you know earlier you know I
haven't been out to dinner with Ryan in
a while and I man I really should go
walk around but I'm gonna tell him yes
anyway because I don't want to hurt his
feelings
you know first up I don't want Josh to
make that decision like I want him when
he tells me yes I wanted to I want him
to mean yes I certainly don't want a
pity dinner but that's my answer I don't
want a pity dinner tastes awful no I
guess what I'll say is you know
regardless of whether you tell your
friends yes or no as long as you're
honest with them that's what really
matters
yes thanks Amy
[Applause]
howdy hello what's your name
I'm Kim thank you I live about eight
blocks due east of here do I hear ten
blocks first do you do interventions
what do you think this is actually so
I'm just kind of curious to keep my
questions short in that what went what
year did you say you guys started kind
of this Trek like how long has this been
circa 2009 okay so I was just curious to
what extent if any did the housing
banking crash and all that and no wait
did that kind of help you like oh we're
on the right path here kind of thing
yeah yeah definitely so so I think that
that life goes in cycles right and so
2008 was a strange year because in the
corporate world I was in 2008 is sort of
when I had reached this pinnacle I was a
director of operations for a whole bunch
of retail stores and Ohio Kentucky and
Indiana and I once the crash happened
like we had to start downsizing and it
was a weird a weird thing that happened
to me it was late 2010 we had downs with
got through several rounds of downsizing
and I got really good Josh what it was
right-sizing
oh yeah that's right that's what they
told me that was actually the the
language HR encouraged us to use we were
right sizing I've got some good news
you've been right sized
now no I saw I I had to go through I got
really good at firing people basically
laying them off and never enjoyed it but
you know you become something you get
used to over time and there was finally
toward the end of 2010 after several of
these cycles my boss came to me it was a
few weeks before Christmas and he said
well we have to close eight eight more
stores and we have to layoff 42 people
we have two weeks to put together plan
and we're gonna tell everyone as soon as
the hub with a shopping season is over
and I said okay I can do that you know
I've done it before and but I had never
laid off 42 people at a time like I had
laid off that many before but like in
small chunks it's like there are these
drug mules who carry drugs over the
border from Mexico to the United States
and they'll give them like a hundred
balloons filled with heroin but they
don't give them a hundred balloons to
swallow at once they just give you four
balloons to swallow and then they put
four more on the table this time he put
all the balloons on the table and said I
need you to get rid of these 42 people
and you have two weeks to put together
plans so I did I went home and and I was
working on the plan I had this
spreadsheet and I had all these names in
the spreadsheet of like based on the
data I was gonna the data tell the story
right whoever the 42 people we needed to
get rid of the data would tell me who
and I got to that but then it didn't
feel right because these weren't just
names on a spreadsheet
these were fathers and husbands and
daughters and mothers and friends and
family there were people and looking at
on just a spreadsheet was looking at a
rainbow and greyscale and so I put
together the plan in two days and my
name was the first name on the list and
so I laid myself off I said I can't do
this anymore doesn't align with the
person I want to become and so I think
sometime
tragedy whether it's a downturn this is
my short answer by the way sometimes
tragedy illuminates the path it's good
in man I had so much time to think about
something and I was definitely affected
I had to I tried to sell my house I was
so upside down on it that and this was a
few years after the crash it was crazy
cause like in 2008 I was renting and
then I had a friend who sold houses uh
you know this was I think I bought that
house in 2010 so it was a couple years
later and they were telling me like you
know now's the time to buy like this is
prices are low not everything is bounce
back but it is bouncing back you know it
can only get better from here and it did
not get better for my property it kept
it kept losing value so when I went to
go sell it it was impossible to get what
I owed out of it so I ended up renting
it and I still it was like a net
negative $100 so I essentially had to
pay like 100 bucks a month after my
tenant paid their their rent um you know
okay a hundred bucks a month to rent
your house to people yes yeah it was
crazy solid investment mm-hmm and what
I'll say though is I was really I was
really glad though that this thing
called minimalism came into my life
because it really helped me to regain
control of my finances to regain control
of my time so that hundred bucks a month
it's it was a lot of money I was able
because of you know the the habits and
this philosophy I had brought into my
life I was I was able to do that I
really wish I would have started sooner
that I mean that's people always ask me
like what you know
what's the one thing is there anything
you regret and I'm like yeah I really
wish I would have started so much sooner
like the most encouraging thing we've
had happen on this tour this is totally
an aside so I'm sorry I'm like derailing
this question but we were in San Diego
and we were going out with for the
meet-and-greet line to hand out hugs and
as we were walking up to the front of
the line there's these this couple who
has a daughter and they're like go on go
on and she like came up to us and she's
like I'm five I'm like cool and she was
like I just donated a bunch of my
clothes I had no like I was so taken
back by this and I'm like wow here's a
five-year-old girl she is so much
further ahead than me like I really I
wish I would have started so all right I
got to put the answer and I do say this
a little bit tongue-in-cheek start
incorporating minimalism into your life
and now before you're forced into
becoming a minimalist
we have time for one more and so well
will answer one more question I won't
apologize other folks in line I promise
you will get a hug afterward
howdy what's your name I am Marisa hey
Marisa I am from South Bend but I'm
currently moving down to Fort Wayne so
I'm kind of from two places right I
actually have an observation and then a
question as I'm moving and unpacking and
in my fiance's house
I have been listening to the minimalist
and the mine Palace and let me tell you
I get rid of a ton more [ __ ] when I'm
listening to you guys than if I'm just
listening to the radio
just in case stuff is out the door
alright so I had just graduated from
college I paid my way through college so
I am completely debt-free
that is that is amazing thank you I mean
like I think I think debt-free like that
is the new American Dream like that to
me is that that's freedom right there
congratulations thank you and it took me
seven years but I did it and I have
graduated with an English degree because
I am an inspiring an aspiring writer and
a minor in dance and I'm trying to
figure out with me moving into this
brand new place Fort Wayne when I found
out I was graduating you know they were
they were forcing me out I went to the
library and cried because school had
been my safe place for these seven years
and now I'm I'm done and I'm trying to
figure out how to cultivate my passions
and to actually move forward with my
life outside of school and in my safe
place do you guys have any advice yeah
yes so the thing that's safe about
college or factory work or or anything
in that vein is that it's regimented
right it's it's you're told what to do
when to be there when to raise your hand
when to speak and it's a type of cage in
a way right it's it's a well decorated
cage oh here's my pit the answer for you
then
it's it's like a light bulb just turned
on the bird who enjoys her cage still
isn't free oh I thought you had
something you were done dude those are
expensive mics man no not drop that mic
awesome yeah I I think when it comes to
you know cultivating passion you've got
to start somewhere so you know you've
had this routine essentially that's that
was laid out for you and it is hard to
come up with your own routine there's no
doubt about it
and it will take some trial and error
but you know the advice I will give you
is start figuring out what that what
that routine is and it sounds to me like
you're gonna have some time to cultivate
a passion do you have anything standing
out that you like you really want to
cultivate my long-term goal would be to
someday open up my own dance studio and
to be a published author and I am now
that I'm done writing my papers for
school I have started actually writing
my novels and stuff again and I'm trying
to find dance studios in Fort Wayne that
I can start attending and building up
sort of my my repertoire my repertoire
for you know moves and and different
people that I can rely on to help me you
know get better and and stuff cool um it
sounds like two goals two really big
goals and what I was saying earlier I
would definitely say like you've got to
choose one yeah that's no that's awesome
you said you already are writing so
you've kind of already started you know
cultivating that passion yeah I think
that I think you're gonna be okay as
long as you can figure out how to find
that time that you were once spending at
school and and yeah start searching
start doing there start writing more man
I'm really struggling here come up with
a pithy answer it'll come to me hold on
I'm not done yet
it's gonna jump in oh go for it no I was
I was gonna give you a lifeline
thanks man what a friend that's
climate-controlled just know I'll give
you I was trying to give you a pithy
answer oh yeah no so your question is
about cultivating passion um if you just
sit around and aspire there's gonna be
aspiration everywhere
[Applause]
thank you thank you sorry to the rest of
the line folks I really do apologize we
have to move on I'm Way over on time to
our added value segment of the show this
is where Ryan and I talk about things
have added value to our lives recently
and since we're in Indianapolis let's
let's do a little local fit flare Ryan
what's been adding value to your life
here in Indy well first off you got to
give it up for the Egyptian room this is
this an amazing venue or what yeah so
Josh and I we when we lived in Ohio we
would drive to Indianapolis all the time
to see concerts and a lot of them were
here there's another venue called radio
radio that has some has some cool shows
going through it too but yeah that's
that's a cool place I would definitely
check out I ate at this restaurant
earlier today called three carats it's
it was this vegan vegetarian place over
in the Indianapolis City Market is it
myself right yeah it was unbelievable I
mean I saw because God loved Mariah she
has so much like digestion 'el gut flora
stuff going on and so many allergies
that like I saw this vegan vegetarian
place and I was like okay like they're
probably gonna have some stuff for her
um
Jessica's got some similar stuff going
on I'm just gonna tell about everyone's
medical issues on stage apparently but
anyway no we went there and I wasn't
like super looking forward to it because
well I started eating meat a couple
years ago and I mean I love me a nice
big juicy hamburger sometimes you know
so you know we went there and for for uh
for dietary restriction issues and I was
just like blown away so good um although
it always disturbs me a little bit when
they can take a soy product and make it
taste better than like what the soy
product is supposed to represent
like they have these little I forget
what the the name is on the menu but
it's like little buffalo wing bites
it's like it's better than chicken I
mean it's it's so good
but yeah there's two places for sure
actually before I hand this off to you I
just want to say thank you to Mariah
who's on tour with us right now she
she's just an awesome partner and all I
can say is for those of you out there
who have amazing partners you've got to
like wake up and say thank you every day
and you've got to figure out a way to go
to that partner and show them that you
appreciate them every day um it's it's
this is the first time I've ever had a
relationship that was this amazing and
and what she sacrifices to go on the
road with us or if I have to leave her
for a couple weeks it just it makes all
the difference in the world so thanks
more Bryan you mentioned I've seen so
many concerts here but also at radio
Radio the first was the first time that
I saw Andrew Bell perform you all saw
Andrew Bell open up the show today how
about Andrew so can I can I tell you
this we're actually gonna bring him out
here in a second and have him play a
little something Ryan and I we don't
always have the same taste in music but
both of us will tell you the best album
of this decade is his last album that
came out it's called black bear and it's
just such an honor to have him here
tonight and he's got a new album coming
out August 25th
it's called dive deep and we're gonna
bring him out here right now he'll sing
the the title track from from that album
thanks guys that album of the decade
that is
that's a tall order to live up to but we
have two months to live up to it Yeah
right
yeah I really appreciate that a lot this
night this is a my last song it's called
dive deep and I'm just honored to be
able to be here tonight with Joshua and
Ryan playing in front of all you guys
thank you for listening and yeah here
goes
[Music]
this is my
that'd be you something that I wanna
keep we get carried away
goes down I've got nothing to tell them
come on you wanna start oh I don't wanna
stay about Iranian fare risky but you
will let me go I say just so nice Terry
always started a feeling started inside
away you were spying on
I sticking around in space
this is my
[Music]
you started that on a key
we carried away I can understand it with
a dis V New York fellow without you my
future's you can you gotta zip my
photograph II started inside away
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
and on the morning when it has to be
honest at least
[Music]
don't stop
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
we're gonna get Andrew to stick around
for a minute yeah got a few seconds to
chat with us awesome so um you can just
hand him that mic Sean that'd be great
beautiful so so man I've seen you live
maybe three or four times and it's
different every time we're weird
where have you seen yet once I flew to
San Diego just to see you yes Spokane we
drove out the spot we live in Missoula
Montana so like the closest cities
Spokane Amy the Bartlett yeah and then
here and in India we we were radio radio
but anyway
Andrews album that comes up this year
we're looking forward to it if you
haven't checked out black bear it's it's
a phenomenal album Ryan and I play out
albums all the time when we're on the
road and that's one like it just it
won't play out like the cassette won't
break then like he'd followed it up with
like some hushed like some more acoustic
lay yeah of some of the songs on there
and yeah it's like seriously the only um
Ryan I we can just listen to and repeat
and like never get tired of it man all
right we'll do it enough flattery here
you have a really interesting podcast
man you started a podcast recently it's
called stem uh yeah and I'm fascinated
by the concept and also I'm fascinated
by the way that you edit it yeah yeah so
can we talk about the concept with the
podcast because it's unlike anything
that I've heard well so I've been doing
music now for like ten years
my wife is a chef she went to culinary
school and so she's bounced around in
kitchens and stuff and you know I've
always loved to eat but through our
relationship I've become what I describe
as like a you know I can amateur
enthusiast in food you know I never I
don't know do i i'm not like a chef by
any means but i love to cook and we cook
together and she's you know you were
talking about you know your partners
making sacrifices for you my wife does
that very same thing I mean she's kind
of a little bit for gone a career in
food to be able to be flexible enough to
come travel with me on tour and the road
and and so for that reason we've always
thought you know what's a way that we
can marry our love for food and for
music and you know people artists
friends of mine are always coming
through town on tour and somehow they're
always ending up at our house maybe on
the couch or whatever and there's always
food involved and you know just amazing
stories inevitably happen you know when
you're eating a good meal and you're
talking about where people come from and
getting to know them and learning about
them you know through them they'll be
saying oh this reminds me of this or you
know I've got a great story about you
know when I was growing up and my
favorite meal and so we were hearing so
many great stories over the years we
thought there's got to be a way to
document this and first we thought maybe
a blog with like maybe we'd you know
video content and stuff like that but
video editing video is pictures of cats
videos yeah anyways we it took us many
years to figure out that basically the
best format in which to deliver these
stories to an audience who wants to hear
them would be a podcast my wife loves
her probably her favorite thing in the
world does they hear people's stories
about where they come from and and how
they've gotten to you know where they
are today and and food plays such a big
role in that and defining you know and
shaping you as an early you know child
and your family and the food that your
maybe your parents cooked growing up and
and how that kind of your taste develops
and and and then today you know the food
that you're interested in now and found
that there's so many interesting stories
to be told so we started interviewing
artists and we put out a podcast called
Systema or basically we just you know
every episode is a new singer songwriter
or artist of some kind we're thinking
about expanding that beyond songwriters
and yeah we just interview them where
you from
if you had to choose one dish growing up
that sort of defines your childhood what
would that dish be and then we talk
about that and we talk about where they
like to eat on tour and it's like a food
podcast but it's not real
about food it's about memories ya found
through ya through the vehicle of food
anyway yeah and to me I find that for me
food is an entertainment but it can be
that vehicle because my partner is also
just a phenomenal cook here's a great
blog called minimal wellness and and she
is she creates these experiences that
centers around food but it's not the
food that is always the most memorable
thing it's the most delicious thing and
it's my favorite restaurant in Missoula
is our kitchen but but I found that what
I remember most are the experiences we
have around that food and you find a way
to capture it in the way you edit the
podcast is is you have this conversation
with them but then it almost turns into
this monologue the way the edited there
that yeah they're reciting their
childhood memories and going back to
their hometown and you you did one with
Matt words recently and he's just
talking about being back in the Midwest
and yeah and and reliving the childhood
sort of through that that sensory
experience of taste and smell and and
what it's like to dive deep in the ones
John yeah I mean everybody has an
interesting story about where they come
from and and everyone has a story about
like that favorite meal that their their
mom or dad made for them growing up and
yeah I basically edited the way that I
do because I don't like I tried doing
the back-and-forth question-and-answer
thing and I just thought I sounded like
an idiot so I just edited myself out
completely and then I just like narrate
the top and that you know at the end and
I let them just be the feature the
it's really great so check it out it's
called stem ah it's on Apple podcast or
wherever you get podcast I'll put a link
to it in the show notes as well and you
want to thank you so much for being here
guys thank you guys so much thanks
yeah notice how I didn't give him like
one more hug I don't want to creep them
out they're transferable so you can
always pass them on to someone else when
they say you need six six hugs a day for
happiness 12 a day for growth it sounds
like a [ __ ] study but like I'll
totally buy into that the cool thing is
every time you give a hug you get one -
real quick let's move on the right here
right now we'll talk about what's going
on in the lives of the minimalists Ryan
and I are on a forty city tour it's
called the lessons now tour we're in
Indianapolis right now if you take any
photos you were to share anything online
you want to see other people sharing
things use the hashtag less is now
that's the name of the tour and if
you're listening to this at home and you
want to come see us in any of those 40
cities you can find all the cities over
at less is now.com also this is usually
the part where we talk about all of our
sponsors right what mattress are we
promoting today someone the cat code
that was that's an avid podcast listener
I have a friend who said that uh
podcasts were invented as a conspiracy
just to sell mattresses for those of you
who listen to other podcasts they seem
to be all over the place is a delay
there's food delivery services Ryan we
could always talk about that or
underwear yes
sweat wicking underwear everyone hears
the truth you hear 5000 advertisements a
day and we don't want you to hear 5,000
and one and it costs us a lot of money
to do that in fact the amount of
advertisers that we turn down at this
point we get three million or so people
a month the listen to the podcast is
astounding so if you want to support the
minimalists podcast you can do that you
can just go to the minimalists com you
can click on the donate button there we
set up something called patreon so you
can donate on a per episode basis and I
just want you to know that none of that
money goes to me
or Ryan wait
I thought we were getting minimalist
jets I need like t-shirts with the truth
is that it does cost a lot of money to
do some of the things we want to do
we're trying to open up a podcast studio
we want to do some more experimental
things with the podcast I'm gonna do
shorter episodes longer episodes bring
some guests on we also want to do some
videos we're gonna hire a full time film
filmmaker we also want to be able to
continue to pay podcasts on a full-time
living wage wage his family and three
kids certainly appreciate that and so we
don't make any money off the podcast
other than what you do to support it so
if you wanna head over to the
minimalists com click on donate
join the patreon folks we have over 500
patrons right now that that list is
growing of folks and we also give away
some exclusive podcasts and different
exclusive live streams to the folks
there we want to do a whole lot more
with video we're gonna do a whole lot
more with podcast but only if we have
enough people willing to support us so
we're looking for about 1% a little less
than 1% of our audience to be able to
contribute in some way and we'll be able
to use that money to do something really
cool I want to thank some folks but
before we before we head out of here
we'll be back there in about 20 minutes
or so and we'll say it hi if you want to
stick around come up and say hi we think
Sean we think Jessica we thank the
theater oh we think Andrew you know who
else we should thank you thank you for
being here tonight you know what you
call it cost you some money to to show
up here tonight and we're grateful for
that allows us to rent a really awesome
theater like this and pay all the staff
and the security and all those things
but you gave up more than your money you
give up your time and your attention and
those are your two most precious
resources and we're grateful you decided
to spend an evening with us and so if
you leave here with just one message we
hope it's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thank you thank you Indianapolis
[Applause]
hi my name is Taylor and I'm from Tampa
Florida I was listening to the Nostalgia
episode and as someone who's a younger
minimalist I don't have a whole lot of
things necessarily but I did have a lot
of t-shirts that I had accumulated from
high school and also from college events
and they all do trigger a lot of great
memories for me but they were really
clogging up my closet and so from the
transition after college I actually took
all of the t-shirts and tucked them up
and made a no-sew blanket so I suggest
that anyone who has a lot of t-shirts
that would be a useful way for them to
get a use out of them it's a great size
it's small I can travel with it when I
go across the state or when I get on
just keep all those little things that
might trigger a nostalgia about an event
you went to or about maybe a club you
joined without having the extra bulk hi
Josh you're mine this is Bianca speaking
I'm calling from the Netherlands I have
a tip for Ryan and his double swimming
trunk dilemma and a travel tip in
general I hope ryan told us he didn't
like packing an extra set of swimming
trunks just in case the first one got
dirty on the trip personally I am asking
you dr. Bronner's all one castile soap I
have to add that I have no way shape or
form affiliated with this company
dr. Bronner sells a pure cast iron
liquid soap which can be used for over
18 different purposes you can use this
to clean your face body hair dishes
laundry the whole shebang
so while you're traveling you only need
this show and Ryan you can hand wash
your swimming trunks I also love this
company for using organic and certified
Fairtrade ingredients plus DEP kitchen
recyclable bottles I really like a
philosophy on how to treat the earth and
their suppliers I think this will appeal
to many fellow minimalists I hadn't
heard a recommendation on dr. Bronner so
before so I hope this will help some of
you
hi this is Linda in Kansas City Missouri
responding to the podcast about
nostalgia I donated my yearbooks to the
Midwest geology Center they were happy
to receive them I also plan to donate
some historical regional history books
for Waubonsee County Kansas and the like
because they contain histories of the
people who migrated in subtlety area
this way they are resources for other
people and I'm not the custodian
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without
[Music]
every little thing that you got a hand
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for you gotta grab oh I bet
that you'll be fine without you
so tear your eye or two
[Music]
you